we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
uh the term cultural marxism is one that
is being bandied about
by some on the right recently that's
exactly
what today's voicemail deals with let's
take a listen to it and then i'll tell
you about it
here we go hey david this is steven from
virginia
and i uh just wanted to talk to you
about i've been seeing
a lot of people throw around the phrase
cultural marxism
and i i don't know if you know that or
other people know that but that's
kind of a call back to the conspiracy of
cultural bolshevism uh from world war ii
and the nazis and it's a pretty
anti-semitic
sort of uh dog whistle it is so
anytime you hear someone talk about
cultural marxism
it should be a red flag for you that
absolutely
and cultural marxism the
cultural marxism is presented by the
right as some kind of serious thinkers
hypothesis it's really a conspiracy
theory with some significant
anti-semitic twists
it's kind of like political correctness
on steroids and the idea is that
the originators of cultural marxism who
are often
jewish when you look at the theories are
secretly trying to subvert
the culture of the united states into a
marxist culture so it's less about
economic marxism but it's the idea
of often jewish philosophers
sometimes involving columbia university
figuring out a way to subvert american
society and culture
with cultural marxism rather than than
economic
marxism and it is it is bigoted
it's quacky and wacky and uh so
there's a lot of different flavors where
sometimes the perpetrators are black
people
sometimes it's lgbt folks sometimes it's
the left
often it's jews and um it should be a
when you hear cultural marxism it should
indeed be a red flag and i'm glad that
the caller is pointing it out
we have a great bonus show for you today
don't miss it
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com